From Wimpy to wonderful with flat ribs.
Using ribbing for hems and cuffs
goes in and out of style.
Recently, planning a sweater,
I wanted a ribbed look at the hems and
cuffs, but I didn't want them to pull in.
Plus, I was using a very fine yarn.
The light bulb came on and I
thought of flat ribs.
This technique utilizes the full needle
rib up with your ribber,
but you determine the appearance of the
stitches on the public side of the work.
This is Vancouver yarn from Yeoman Yarns.
It's about 3,600 yards per
pound, and it's very fine.
Even knit at the finest tension
on my standard machine, a one by one
rib in this yarn is loose and wimpy.
Right off the machine, compare
the one by one with a flat rib.
After blocking, the difference
is even more pronounced.
Using heavier yarns with more body produce
a beautiful fabric with this technique.
Choosing different needle setups,
even adding eyelets, opens a whole
world of possibilities for you.
Experienced ribber bed users will be
inspired to incorporate flat ribs
for hems, but for fabulous garments
that won't cling in the wrong places.